oh hi welcome to game
um of life been going on this past week
and we here at game life do not want you
to remain ignorant any longer so here is
a wrap up of this week's news
zynga announced that it has released
farmville 2 in the hopes that the 3
million grandmothers still playing
farmville will be encouraged to pack up
their virtual homesteads and head for
greener pastures uh zynga said that
farmville 2 actually has 3d graphics for
the first time finally bringing zynga in
line with the old nintendo 64. i always
think i've actually figured out a way to
cheat in farmville 2. i just lobbied the
government for massive subsidies and now
i get paid facebook credits to not click
on anything
valve released its green light service
for steam this week allowing game
developers to pitch their games and for
steam community members to vote on
whether or not those games should be
available on the steam store
initially it was free to submit a game
which caused the service to be flooded
with clearly fake games like half-life
three uh and then what happened was
valve said okay well now you've gotta
make a hundred dollar donation to
child's play before you can upload any
games and people then got angry at this
of course saying that it was
exclusionary look guys i've got the
solution to your problem you can release
a game on green light if and only if you
sit through someone singing the song
still alive on rock band
if you can do that you are clearly
committed
valve also started pulling down any and
all games off of steam green light that
had any kind of sexual content meaning
that my autobiographical game i'm
developing is still in the running
alex hutchinson director of assassin's
creed 3 recently told an interviewer
that his game being made by hundreds of
people in studios around the world is
quote the last of the dinosaurs proving
that alex hutchinson was absent from
school that day when they told them what
actually happened to the dinosaurs
in other ubisoft related news the
publisher said that it would no longer
require players of its single-player pc
games to be connected to an always
online internet service just to play the
single player games gamers celebrated
this move ubisoft said it was all due to
the giant meteor headed towards them
that's it for game life this week thank
you and good night
you